hey who's got a fingernail and calling
everything this guy oh my god I get like
both of them it's just sort of so you
get it it's alright but if I mentioned
something my Agron no I got most of it
but it's well no this is this is what I
said in Avatar it's like well you can
you give something away that wasn't even
been important but I'm just like you
know Doug's not an idiot he can
generally figure these things out um so
well I am an idiot I just wasn't about
this but even that I did totally get it
I thought actually the airbending being
opened up after the other elements are
taken away I thought that was clever
I actually liked that too yeah we just
add something like weight cuts off your
connection to the element so I kind you
sever that connection then you've just
got the air laugh so since like tada
like I don't know it was kind of cute
and again it sort of made sense because
as they say you know surfer Louis moment
her powers are gone so it's like using
just whatever she knows of the element
there and that would probably result in
everything so I like that you for
something that's kind of made up it's
like it did sir I have this logic to it
oh you figured it out pretty well
oh now but so so this is a good final
episode I really enjoy it I like all the
twists I like I love the way uh mom goes
out I mean everything having to do with
the mod in this episode was like perfect
tell me about the rabbits wonderful now
you know in season two it's gonna be
like no I jumped off of the boat just
before the explosion happy you know I
think something like that
I don't think he's coming they made it
look pretty final um I I'm pretty sure
they didn't know if there was going to
be a season two so I think they were
writing a character off um the love
triangle I guess is finished but boy I
guess the the daughter sort of gets the
shaft now she had no yet against
bullying yeah there you go it should be
the other way around I like coram Bowen
much more
actually I do agree with you I think my
thought was a much better couple um look
it doesn't tell me how much we hate the
love triangle they were just like you
know oh I like them together better I
think okay I don't hate the love
triangle I hate the longer angles I am
I'm different to the love triangle I've
seen better
I've seen worse I like I like the way
everything started tied together with
Iroh on the plane and it crashing into
the mass knocking the mascot is like you
guys yeah no that was really good um so
it's a good strong finish I like they
serve use for the most part I kneel
together I don't know what to think
about her giving all the powers back I
like that she had to go through things
she had Korra I mean because avatar did
this - it wasn't a used as machina
essentially and I mean it it kind of was
I mean it's okay like put this way the
airbending you could figure out I did
but you could figure out that even if
it's taken away that could work I'm
talking with the first avatar doesn't
know the first avatar I'm saying like
well wait you can't really you still
can't quite pinpoint like you know this
is what's going to happen it's no
there's no way to figure out here you
could up until when Aang shows up and
gives her back the power um but even
then I'm against I'm just half on it I'm
not again okay here's there's like a
couple different things going on because
they didn't know they were coming back
you know maybe they were just like maybe
we need to wrap this up in a nice tight
happy ending because we don't know
what's gonna be sequels or whatever
there's that in my opinion I would also
argue well this could open yourself up
though I know they're doing or - doing
whatever you want with it like that's
sort of what I was seeing it will tell
you it's open for another season I mean
for me it's not I mean let's say they
they want to give her powers back
I you could make an argument I'm like if
you can communicate with the other
avatars and stuff and this was passed
from the space tortoise or whatever to
Aang then you know in theory and
pass the ability on to her and unlock
her powers to me that it's piano it's
not a deus ex machina what bugs me about
it is that it happened so quickly yeah
and its light was part of the criticism
I had with the first avatar that I liked
the idea I just thought it was executed
a little too fast yeah and say this one
goes with this one's even way worse in
my opinion because my powers you nailed
it
that's basically it Wow is that really
the lowest moment no it's I never go
through a journey of our lowest moment
he'll let her go to let her go through
the journey he let her come out saying
realizing that maybe she didn't need the
power she still has airbending it she's
I mean that still something there was no
let that's the promise there was no
lesson learned or earned really like it
needed if you're gonna do this all in
one season it needed one extra episode
where you show her dealing with it and
therefore her bow is back yeah but she's
you Lansing three minutes
you know nice it's a great moral I mean
that's that's the old Zen Buddhist
saying and you see it in Fight Club -
you know only when we've lost everything
are we free to do anything
yeah but they missed a great opportunity
because what that also means is once
you've lost everything then you're free
to do anything she could have done
something that wasn't purely from the
ass-kicking avatar perspective she could
have helped rebuild the city show people
that you know I'm only an airbender now
but I'm gonna do what I can I'm like I'm
gonna learn the same way that that guy
learned how to do blood bending without
the full moon and take away the the
power and stuff like that why couldn't
she learn the same ability to get the
other forces back and she could only do
it at her lowest moment and when she
tried to bring his stuff back up she I'm
with you she didn't really learn
anything she hit the lowest moment which
is great
but even she didn't really know she hit
the lowest why Oh huh and it's you know
go from there that starting point
episodes of journeying and trying to
figure this out and this is force I gets
a turtle yeah like you got this idea
that even
though you know it was rushed and
handled quickly I felt it was so much
better handled in the first avatar that
I was like okay it ties together it was
a little rush but this one I think what
offends me the most is the whole oh go
go back mock oh yeah you know go back
because I'm not the Avatar anymore and I
just want to be alone you know he says I
love you and she's like I owe ya more a
love triangle bullish um you know and I
get in Tenzin's like she needs to deal
with this she needs to be alone but what
bothers me is second she gets her powers
back did you notice what happened I love
you - I love you - I'm like oh so now
that everything's worked out for you I
guess you can go out with yeah I know
that really bugged me and the thing is
it wouldn't have bugged me had you done
this over the course of a whole 24
minute episode I would have been fun
even half an episode or even half an
episode but when it went that quickly I
was like wow it just made her look like
a douchebag well now that I got my
powers back well why Quinn okay why
couldn't they stop the episode where she
you know she runs off and she's looking
out over the horizon she's crying then
maybe she stands up and maybe Marco
comes behind her it's like you know what
are you gonna do it's like you know I do
you think you'll ever get your powers
that you know I don't know but I'm gonna
go find out or something like that you
leave it open for another season or
could end there I mean if you wanna be a
nice open ending I would have gone with
a term Terminator 2 ending you know I
don't know what the future holds
yeah but I'm gonna find that like had
you done that then and then this would
be like maybe three or four episodes of
the next season or something or if not
if it ended there that'd be okay - you
see I like how final it could have been
with first of all with her losing all
her powers I I was actually leaning
towards the average weight but then it's
like she sells the airbending oh okay so
she has something well they can still
make a season out of that and but she
still lost something she has to adapt
this is a good mix but then she just
gets it back and now she's gonna be I'll
say they start throwing the Jesus
element of now she's the healer she's
bringing back the power bringing back
the life which bugs me too because then
these people don't have to adapt they
don't have to adapt to this stuff and I
think that would have been a really good
lesson
interesting you nailed it and this is
the biggest issue I have what made tough
and you know I hate seeing this cuz I
love the creators of this show but I'm
just gonna call them out on this what
what made Toph such a great character is
it she is a girl with a disability that
learned how to adapt and turn into
something amazing turn to the great yeah
which gave us then beifong how
interesting would have been if Lin
beifong now has to adapt and maybe gets
herself wrapped up in the new technology
as a way to continue yeah I could have
done with you I'm having the abilities
gone I think that's a great point with
talk because if anything having her
sight taken away has increased her earth
and you could have done it with Korres
well you could have done it with limb
instead it just becomes like well no
everything's okay after all you didn't
have to sit there and deal with this
which is very strange because these
creators are normally so good at that
yeah but it's just and I don't know if
maybe I mean I know what it's like in
the writing process we've done projects
together where stuff goes wrong I don't
know if they got under the gun here and
we're just like we gotta wrap this up
quickly if some focus group was like
depressing I have no clue what heaven or
maybe that was just the original idea
yeah it could have been maybe they I
don't wanna saw it but there's so good
at that bet to see them kind of do this
sort of you know wrap it up in a neat
little package happy ending I was like
wow you guys sold yourself a little
shorter than that cuz you guys have done
such a great work and this one it just
didn't quit yeah it's kind of a shame I
mean the only way I could see it is
maybe sort of like the only thing I can
think of is maybe like Polar Express
where it's like he thinks he loses the
belt okay spoilers everyone see that
Christmas movie but uh you know where he
thinks he loses the Bell and then like
at the very end he gets it back and but
he still went through that loss and it
really showed that loss it's only there
and served when he lost you know you
felt like like he was saying the lowest
moment but there did you really feel
like she was at her lowest moment or
whatever I mean there was no because it
was so much I mean I was like this is
the beginning of the lowest moment but
what bothers me no I'll tell you why I
don't
think it was their lowest moment what
bothers me about it is the dude
confessed his love for her that's an
honest moment
typically here's here's what here's what
would have made it the lowest moment if
he confessed love and she's like I know
I can't and he gets upset he's like fine
screw this I'm done we're over
we're through so now she has lost
absolutely everything maybe then I could
see what I love it's stupid to it I
guess but dumb blonde triangle but and
again it's not if they want to do that
I'm actually okay and again if they want
to give her her powers back and have her
give everybody their powers back yeah
I may not be the best idea but I'm like
it can work idea it was so rushed I
don't know if that's a Nickelodeon on
them or just yeah like I'm not like this
very very Raj I'm not theory as a show
for what years for what the ending is
it's more uncurious for when it could
have been for what these creators have
been a grave done and could have done um
but for what it is it's it's your happy
ending and it's like okay it doesn't
betray everything it's just more Man
what could have been done here logically
I don't find fault in than just like
logically I didn't find fault in the
whining turtle
so it's just more how it's handled and
executed then if the lion turtle hit a
couple issues here and there this to me
he's just got a ton yeah this is like a
whole psychiatrist session of issues um
but okay so I got a few more minutes
here I just I'll do a quick just a quick
wrap-up of the show in general um I
think it just as a whole I started to
going in it wasn't gonna be as good as
avatar so I wasn't expecting it to be um
I like that it's different I like it
went this different route you know and
these different characters and stuff um
I really I think it comes down to start
off really strong and it's for the most
part really strong I I don't like the
last few minutes but it's it still ended
really really strong with the climax and
everything and it came through I was
afraid when but the middle part like I
said I think sorry with Korra and the
main
three or four characters there I don't
think just we're strong enough compared
to Avatar but as a family show in
general as a Nickelodeon show still I
think it's good I still think it's a
good show it could have been stronger
and I know it's not gonna be avatar uh
but I still like it was why you need to
compare it to avatar because it has same
series its displace in the same world
okay it's like comparing Batman and
Batman Returns it's it is the sequel and
and that's what you're going to compare
it but again I don't need to be as good
as avatar I to me it's more like trying
to compare the burden Batman's with the
Nolan Batman so these are the same
people these are the same people but
it's really stylistically different no
but it's it still matches that well
still the same world it's still the
continuation and but I guess I'm not
expecting it to be the next I'm not
expecting it to be avatar if I wanted
something different I'm glad I got
something different uh as a whole legacy
is sort of the middle section where I
really started to get out of it but then
it comes back and I like these issues I
like the direction it went and I like
that sir went a more challenging route
with with the story and with the with
the villain especially I thought this is
much more challenging stuff for kids I
wished the same amount of challenge with
the characters the main characters
anyway with korimako and stuff that was
in the original avatar was here if it
was I think he could have been maybe
even on par with avatar but for what it
is I thought was good I I did like the
show strongest monster when it began to
when it ended I thought so I yeah the
love triangles that the best thing on
the plan but I thought it was really not
intrusive overall but I've sat through a
lot of bad love triangles and animated
things so well you had to sit through a
lot romantic comedies - yeah well my
wife likes romantic comment I guess easy
go out of this I've seen a lot of
this marry the rich snob yeah
so I hope it doesn't bother and the
thing is I do agree with you that it's
not that core is the issue Mach oh I
think is the weak link here yeah this
one that group in general that doesn't
as a personality but that's the thing
when I say the weak link we're talking
about a whole set of good characters
overall and there's nothing bad about
Mach oh it's just know that nothing in
this show lonely is the other show where
some of the weaker characters made that
on the periphery it's a couple of the
central characters like that I'm just
gonna say maka mostly I like something I
like such as daughter
I like Bolin you know in my cough
interesting and then sort of became very
bland but yeah but I'm sorry with you if
they're nothing in the show is there and
they're fine character yeah yeah no I I
thought was a great job I love the
revolution aspect to it I loved him on
it I was wondering I was like man how
you gonna go from Mark Hamill like how
are you gonna trade up on that I'm like
oh well what I'm warming okay well I'll
say how you gonna trade up from from
Zuko and those feelings are so complex
and interesting here they did the exact
opposite they covered him in shadow and
you didn't know much about it and they
slowly reveal that gemin imperfect both
Noah talked and tarrlok speaking of
names if you don't want us to get the
names wrong let's not good with
complicated names like I know what Lord
speaking of names okay
Sokka is sok ka oh my god no no no I
just realized something
we really got in Korra like this ya know
cuz I just know I just realized
something as I was saying them and
that's pronounced Sokka
Cora is spelled Kor are a weren't we
pronouncing it Cara I I don't know but
I'm just wondering I'll give you a ship
for it they'll say here's the exact
definition and like the toking library I
probably say eldest names and how they
should say it in Cora as well know it
together and say if they had an exact
dictionary this would have been way
better yeah sure what about
the names would have made sense maybe
that's something the makers of the show
the creators can sell technically I
don't think they don't have the time
they're like yes I probably watching
this to like you know guys like me at
all yeah I think they just looked up a
bunch of Asian names there's like which
is fine oh yeah but then we get crap for
it all the time I got your names
whatever so there you go
Legend of Korra is it really a legend
yes are clear that this happened I go
with the chronicles of course yeah you
know Righetti is a name the legend
actually actually the no no no it should
be like cuz they do the newsreel it
should be like the life and times of
times of course the person to person of
korra so yeah there you go
good good show it is a good show and i
enjoyed it again still miles beyond what
a lot of glowing the shows have done and
I'm glad they decided to do just ripping
on Nickelodeon altogether now yeah
normal calculate the quality is fine but
they do stuff like spongebob random city
goofy funny haha it's like your stuff
it's like hey we're gonna knock it into
another okay okay okay let's looks like
I'm nuts here I mean core is definitely
no spongebob that's true she could she
could use that lay up a little bit more
could you see her waterbending spongebob
one finding spongebob that'd be
wonderful we're done I
I smell the second season core odds but
Bobby they're going there you go Patrick
could be a spirit fish hire us as
writers man we got great ideas right
here so um yeah we're actually ending on
that note so Legend of Korra
meet spongebob next bit off the last
sponge bender I hide